PRESIDENT WHO ALWAYS LOOKS AT
THE DATA, AS DR. FAUCI AND
DR. BIRX HAVE REPEATEDLY NOTED.
>> Reporter: KAYLEIGH, THERE
IS A SECOND CONFIRMED CASE OF
COVA NATION AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY.
A MEMBER OF THE VICE PRESIDENT
STAFF.
THAT’S TWO IN TWO DAYS IN A
BUILDING WHERE PEOPLE ARE BEING
TESTED NOW, INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT AND THE VICE PRESIDENT
COME EVERY DAY AND HAVING THE
TEMPERATURE CHECKED.
WHY SHOULD THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THESE RAPID
TESTS STILL GO TO WORK, WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE ISN’T EVEN SAFE FOR
PEOPLE?
>> Secretary McEnany: THIS
INDIVIDUAL, THERE IS A MEMBER OF
THE VICE PRESIDENT’S TEAM WHO IS
POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS.
WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE THE
GUIDELINES THAT ARE EXPERTS HAVE
PUT FORWARD TO KEEP THIS
BUILDING SAFE, WHICH MEANS
CONTACT TRACING, ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDED GUIDELINES, THESE
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS.
WE ARE PUTTING THEM IN PLACE
HERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.